reverse what started out as a high-speed
chase turns into a foot chase when
suspects jump out of a vehicle in front
of Wisconsin officers and foot bail foot
bail foot bail three
occupants the entire incident stemming
from an alleged retail theft at a Dick
Sporting
Goods keep your hands in your
back
please don't
be my
arm it all started on October 3rd in
Wawatosa Wisconsin just outside of
Milwaukee that's where police were
tipped off about a retail theft at an
area Dicks Sporting Goods dash camera
video shows an officer catch up with a
suspect's
vehicle
you good hang I can go back up
46 yeah you
[Applause]
can when the suspect refuses to stop
along the interstate an officer can be
heard calling in the
pursuit 146 vehicle is not stopping
we're North bomb
41 57 mph looks like exent
[Applause]
Capital hey F you can put me on Pursuit
right now going eastbound
[Music]
Capital 146 Adam Adam 4645 negative Curr
2020 hry color L darana Anderson 7849
60th 10 we still East Capital speed
59 traffic
medium but after taking an offramp the
suspect stops on the side of the road
behind another vehicle We're stopped
right now about the 1100 block of
Capital Foot still on the brake I don't
know if they're going to keep going
they're behind a disabled vehicle
the officer calls in for backup saying
he's worried the car May speed off again
he also calls for Stop Sticks just in
case the driver makes a break for
it 146 I'll wait for another vehicle to
come in case I accident they take off
again again we're eastbound Capital
about the 1100
block temp
for 115 160 coming
104 one just wants to set up sticks
ahead of us just in case minutes later
another officer arrives on the scene do
you want me to approach and then if they
take off you can go
sure that works how many do you know how
many occupants or anything maybe two huh
maybe two hard to tell at the T
okay is he set up yet I didn't hear him
say he was set up yet
yeah
[Applause]
looks like he's almost there what looks
like he's almost there at 102
okay while the first officer stays in
his squad car the other approaches the
suspect's vehicle on foot 606 is going
to approach their foot's still on the
brake and if they try to take off again
I'll follow can you make announcements
for them to roll down their windows
[Applause]
Yep driver of the Camry roll all your
windows down
now
driver of the
Camry roll your windows down now the
officer calls for the suspect to roll
down the windows but they refuse
officers note their vehicle is not in
park and could take off at any
minute dep
window
[Applause]
23 set up by Grand
Capital 146 606 is trying to make
contact we're not getting compliance
with the driver to roll the windows down
f break this continues on as officers
remain ready for the suspect to speed
off 146 to 606 I just saw the front
wheels
move you want to grab my sticks and try
and slide them under the car yeah on
driver's side in case they try and take
off soon another officer brings out a
set of Stop Sticks and places them under
the suspect's
car
got sticks in front of the vehicle right
now one
more it's only seconds later that the
driver throws the car in reverse and
starts to take off but the officer
behind the car is still ready for a
Chase and speeds off after the suspect's
car
reverse contact and 146 vehicle's taken
off again continues as the suspect
weaves in and out of
traffic and 146 vehicle taken off again
looks like the stick's
hit we are East B on Capital speeds are
60 traffic is medium they are weaving it
in and out of
[Applause]
traffic there still
be about two BLS ahead of
Speed
video
the suspect even tops 90 mph and runs a
red light 146 speed's 90 he's found
Capital approaching
92 they just went through the red
light suddenly the car starts smoking
and appears to have lost a tire it's
then that m multiple suspects hop out
and Sprint
[Applause]
away and we're still eastbound on capit
all they're
approaching 85
now they are Smoky right now looks like
they're losing a
tire and we just turn Southbound on A4
Southbound for
Capital and foot bail foot bail foot
bail three occupants dash camera video
shows the officer Rush from his Squad
and call for the remaining suspect to
get down
down I got one occupant down on the
ground looks like a passenger took off
going Westbound and the driver took off
going eastbound that's when the chase
continues on foot as officers searched
through a nearby neighborhood for the
suspect who ran in that
direction yeah it was a crashed at like
84 84 Southeast corner of capital into
like that old first
store yeah I think
so what was going on we switch to many
channels as I travel from each district
when a police canine starts barking
First Responders are quick to notice a
suspect hidden behind a garbage can the
woman was later identified as Dariana
Anderson hey get your hands up hands up
hands up you going to get bit come
on come on get your hands up I see you
behind the garbage can face away from me
face away face away show me your hands
show me your hands all right good boy I
I got I got cover on KNE on knees let's
get her get her get on your knees drop
down your knees should to hold back
buddy my bad keep your hands in your
back officers act quickly putting
Anderson in
handcuffs please don't
be my
arm
hold on where'd you put your
phone much coinci with that
animal
camera sure
when asked Anderson doesn't tell the
officers her name and instead just asks
for water what's your name just RI
what's your
name what's your name can I get some
water okay I just want to make sure I
see that the top was ripped was that did
you get bit by the dog at
all anywhere no okay I just want okay
we'll we'll take care of that in just a
second all right I'm just confirming
that you have yeah you didn't get bit
that was already there okay all right
stand up for us all right
that you want to continue uh we only had
one going this way so I think this is
yep okay we're going to walk you back
out to the front then okay with that
officers escort Anderson into a squad
car check here for any other
evidence they did
not and after that the officers
congratulate the the police can9 on a
job well done so so what what caught me
was you know I saw what you saw like oh
he definitely is interested he defin
interested and then I came around I'm
like okay there's nothing there and I
didn't see I couldn't tell it's a person
here but then when I got to here I could
see what looked He barked and like oh
he's barking at something I thought
maybe yeah my bad but like I said for
nature she was passive H uh basically
back against here and knees out in front
sitting sorry well ke Us in though at
least I know I I I was like up it's
something there you know oh man had a go
bull yeah Anderson was taken into
custody and now faces multiple charges
including eluding an officer and retail
theft she's since been released on
$1,500 cash Bond reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie